hello han lu kobato from Microsoft
Research Cambridge so what we what we
are working on is new experiences where
we use some machine learning
technologies and we embed them inside
tools such as Excel people love to use
Excel to to work with data and we are
trying to assist users in the whole
pipeline of acquiring data and analyzing
them so an example of the other things
you can do with these tools is this is a
sheet of expenses I got from my bank and
the task I want to do is to label these
entries into various categories such as
food or bills or entertainment so if I
start doing that for instance the first
one would be food and this one would be
for instance other as soon as I have two
entries for this Colin the tool is
trying to basically learn what are the
characteristics of each category and to
suggest the user ways when it has enough
confidence what's the right label so for
instance all of these entries are
accurately categorized as food and if I
continue just a little bit for instance
this would be a bail so some bill
entries start appearing and if I feel
one more or let's say as entertainment
we already have a few more entry so I
get quite a few entries for each click
with this application so it's a much
more productive way of labeling data so
another example using the same machinery
in technologies with a different context
is when you want to analyze data so for
instance here we have a table of partial
data but the votes of US Senators then
we have a number of missing values so
for instance we don't have the
affiliations for a few of the setters we
don't have for instance the percentage
often how many times they followed the
party vote for a few of them and we have
a number of missing ages and nays for a
number of issues so what this story is
doing here is a slightly different
experience where I just select a range
and I can press this autocomplete button
which will analyze the data and propose
values for the missing
sells so for instance we can see that
john kerry's predicted to be rightly a
democrat the other thing that this tool
is doing is that it's also highlighting
values that stand out so for instance
here this value is highlighted as an
outlier and we are excited about this
these new experiences because we think
it's real way to democratize machine
learning machine learning currently is
really only usable by a small number of
specialists and we think that with the
right simple experience within Microsoft
products such as Excel there is really a
way to open it up to a broad range of
people